estamos en vencimiento en el sureste de
ucrania este campo de desplazados está
bajo el control de la autoproclamada
república del túnez las autoridades
prorrusas dicen que han acogido aquí a
varios cientos de ucranianos que han
logrado salir de la sitiada mariupol a
unos 20 kilómetros de distancia
todas las casas están destruidas la
gente va a buscar agua bajo las bombas
este rastreo en
el jefe de la inteligencia militar
ucraniano dijo este domingo que moscú
intenta dividir al país al anunciar que
las fuerzas rusas se centrarán en
liberar el donbass mientras tanto en
mariupol más de 100.000 personas siguen
esperando para abandonar la ciudad pero
las evacuaciones siguen realizándose de
forma fragmentada nación yugos oro y se
ha autorizado dos corredores
humanitarios en la región de dos nietos
y lugansk en la región de dos nietos se
trata de la ciudad de mariupol y sap
orilla con vehículos privados porque más
al oeste en la ciudad de mykolaiv el
último bastión antes de llegar a la
estratégica o de esa también está en
alerta máxima las tropas ucranianas
están decididas a luchar hasta el final
protegeremos nuestro país y nuestra
libertad y nuestra democracia
pase lo que pase lucharemos hasta la
muerte y tendremos una nueva vida para
nuestras familias nuestra democracia y
nuestra ucrania web deben
tras semanas de intensos combates parece
que la soga se afloja según los
observadores el frente ruso ha
retrocedido gracias a una ofensiva de
las tropas ucranianas über gerson 80
kilómetros de distancia